That wall that I have right there
would have been the mission wall
that surrounded the Alamo.
And that's the wall that the Mexican
troops hit.
I'm right in the battlefield of why
Texas is Texas.
Vince Cantu runs Moses Rose's,
a San Antonio, Texas, bar
that's on the site of the famous
1836 battle memorialized
on the big screen many times by the
likes of John Wayne and Billy Bob
Thornton.
He opened Moses Rose's in 2010
after it had sat vacant for many
years.
My family's been here for four
generations running taverns downtown
San Antonio.
I'm proud of my family.
My great grandfather had a tavern
four blocks that way.
My grandmother had a restaurant.
My grandfather had a restaurant less
than a quarter mile that way.
I feel like I am on the shoulders of
giants. I like what I do and I like
where I do it.
I never really thought about it
happening to me until it happened to
me. I've been living under the
threat of eminent domain for six
years.
The Alamo Trust, a nonprofit
that manages the site, wants to
expand the Alamo Museum, which
would include building a theater and
a civil rights exhibit where Moses
Rose's currently stands.
Cantu says that in 2016,
the group made its first offer of
$1,000,000 signed by
then–Land Commissioner George Bush,
which would have barely covered his
outstanding loans.
Four years later, they upped it to 2
million.
And I've told them no both times.
Mostly because, you know, I'm
60 years old and it puts me out of a
job, come back in ten years and see
what it's worth. And maybe, maybe
that's the way I want to do it,
because I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna
look at ten year money at 3% a year
when it's been appreciating at,
like, 18% a year.
At the outset, the $400-million
museum-expansion project was
supposed to be paid for by private
donors.
When the funding fell through, the
state of Texas stepped in to cover
the cost.
The state made two more offers,
which Cantu rejected.
He said he'd sell for 15 million.
So state officials who declined
to participate in this story,
countered by threatening to take his
property by force using eminent
domain.
Cantu would receive a so-called
fair market price based on
an independent appraiser's estimate
of the property's current value.
The appraisal came in at 2.1
million, or roughly 2.8
million in ten years.
In December, the Alamo Trust offered
3.5 million, which can too
quickly declined.
They keep alleging that you're not
negotiating in good faith.
What do you say to that?
All lies. They've never called me.
So we never really had a negotiation.
They would send me an email with
an offer.
I would send them an email back
saying, "No, thank you," and
some other words. They've wanted to
negotiate with me over my property,
but they wanted a loaded gun to do
it. They've wanted the threat of
eminent domain hanging over my head
for me to take their number instead
of them taking my number.
And running a business when you're
under the threat of eminent domain
is really, really hard.
I mean, you know, because you're, as
a business person, you're looking
out today,
tomorrow, a month from
now, but you're also looking out
five and ten years out to see
what you need. You need a new
system. You need you need to remodel
the place. You need to put some
money into it some other way.
And not knowing whether the
government was going to come in and
take it in at any moment
really kind of defeated the
whole joy I had about
thinking about the future of this
place and in developing ten-year
strategies.
A pissed-off Cantu started tacking
on an extra million dollar fee to
his offer each year that the
government threatened him with
eminent domain.
And earlier this year, George P.
Bush, who's the son of Jeb and the
nephew of George W., called
Cantu's refusal to sell at the
state's price "dishonorable."
I told my wife that if I saw him,
I would challenge him to a duel in
front of the Alamo.
I would use squirt guns, not
real gun, because I want to kill
anybody and I don't want to get
killed. But, you know, I mean,
just, just to avenge my honor.
Bush didn't respond to Reason's
requests for comment.
Proponents of the Alamo's plan
would argue that this
is necessary. It's necessary that
they take these buildings, that they
seized them in order to
expand the, the visitor center
of the new theater that they're
building.
What do you say to those people who
are supporters of the Alamo really
expanding their footprint in the
city?
Well, those people that say that,
that support that,
are the ones that read in the paper
that I would not come to the table.
But the truth is, is that I've told
the museum people for six years that
I would come to the table.
I've been waiting for six years for
my phone to ring for, for
them to sit down and have an honest
negotiation with me.
I've never been in the way of what
they wanted to do. So I would say,
how could I be in the way of
something when I told them I would
sell to them from day one?
They just never have wanted to meet
me even close to my price.
And that's the government saying
we don't have to because we can
eminent domain you instead.
Cantu says that when he started
Moses Rose's, it was in a
dilapidated part of town.
He and his family are being denied
the opportunity to reap the rewards
of more than a decade of sacrifice.
This part of downtown San Antonio
was not a place anybody really came.
It was a bunch of homeless people
here.
My idea was to open up a bar
and grill and
have live music, but most of the
people that played for me
at first were just homeless guys
with guitars. I mean, that's really
kind of what we had over here,
really. And then after a while, it
just kind of started clicking.
Downtown started opening up a little
bit, and this part of downtown
started getting a little bit more
gentrified and a little bit better.
The San Antonio City Council voted
in late January to authorize
the use of eminent domain, which
would allow the city to condemn and
acquire the property to hand to the
Alamo Trust if Cantu doesn't
take their state-backed offer.
After our interview, Cantu met with
the trust's attorneys.
He says they offered him 2.4
million, more than $1,000,000
less than what they'd offered him
before the city started the eminent
domain process.
It was just a bad faith
bullshit negotiation that they
said they had to have
before they would start eminent
domain.
Cantu has vowed to keep fighting.
Texan is small government
and, and fiercely
independent. It's stupidly ironic.
Completely un-Texan.